[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy when you're talking about
Islamophobic hate crimes this one really
tugged at the heartstrings a tear fell
from eleven-year-old Colin Aman's eye as
she recounted according to the Guardian
that an assailant in two attempts within
ten minutes cut the girls hit jab using
scissors while she was walking to school
with her brother on Friday a Toronto
police spokeswoman said Calla herself
said I felt confused scared terrified
I screamed the man just ran away we
followed this crowd of people to be safe
he came again he continued cutting my
head jab again she said she was actually
really scared and addressed her attacker
what you're doing is really wrong you
should not act like this and especially
I'm the kid now that's frightening
heartbreaking and disquieting and
fictional Toronto police ultimately
announced after a detailed investigation
police have determined that the events
described in the original news release
did not happen
asked if the incident was simply a hoax
police spokesman mark Pugwash declined
to say the Toronto District School Board
was likewise terse we are very thankful
it said that this assault did not in
fact happen we won't be commenting
further the Toronto District School
Board was far more loquacious when the
supposed hate crime was first reported
board spokesman Ryan Byrd declared that
school officials had contacted police
and the girl's family as soon as they
were told about the incident Byrd said
this is shocking to learn of this
assault and will be working closely with
police to offer any assistance that we
can in the meantime we're offering
supports to the impacted student and her
family of course Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau got into the act he
stated my heart goes out to the young
girl who was attacked seemingly for her
religion I can't imagine how afraid she
must have been I want her and her family
and her friends and community to know
that this is not what can
is Toronto Mayor John Tory added no
child should ever be afraid walking to
school in Toronto because of what they
are wearing or for any other reason and
I want to assure the family that Toronto
police are investigating investigate
they did and they found that this was
yet another fake Islamic phobic hate
crime and one that followed the
now-familiar pattern the initial false
charge made international headlines
while the news that it was yet another
hoax garnered far less coverage but why
did this incident and so many others
like it happen at all because genuine
anti-muslim hate crimes are thin on the
ground contrary to the ubiquitous
propaganda about muslims in the west
facing widespread persecution
discrimination and harassment but muslim
groups are trying to use these hate
crimes to impose criminal penalties on
criticism of islam as in canada with
motion m103 and so when they don't exist
they have to be invented there are
indeed so many anti-muslim hate crimes
that turn out to have been faked by
muslims themselves that it calls into
question whether any of these incidents
ever really happened at all it is a
peculiarities of our peculiar age that
victimhood would be a prized and coveted
status such that people would fabricate
incidents in which they were treated
cruelly or brutally but this is the
world that we live in in this particular
case kaolin oman is only 11 years old so
the question arises did she fake this
incident in order to get out of a
dangerous situation with her parents
like Yasmin zuwaid the New York City
girl
who fabricated an incident of Trump
supporters pulling offered a jab in the
subway last December to try to conceal
from her strict Muslim father that she
had actually been out with her
non-muslim boyfriend or was kaolin Imam
put up to this by some unscrupulous
victimhood monger in the Muslim
establishment in Canada there should be
an investigation faking anti-muslim hate
crimes is a big business designed to
manipulate public opinion and public
policy and so when these hoaxes are
exposed there need to be consequences
what did calles family know and when did
they know it where any Islamic
organizations involved and in what
there needs to be a full and honest
investigation especially now as Canada
is clamping down on criticism of Islam
in line with that anti islam a phobia
motion m103
but one thing is certain there will be
no such investigation as long as Justin
Trudeau who jumped to sympathize with
Callen Oman but has been silent since
their hoax was exposed remains prime
minister as Lama phobia is still a grim
reality of Canadian life as far as
Trudeau is concerned and no number of
hoaxes is going to change that I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]